first thing I would keep in mind is when
the new president comes in the new
present can walk in with a stack of
papers this high called executive orders
and sit down those literally right after
your knockers and just start signing
them and change the economy overnight
why because the president doesn't have
to ask permission for a whole lot of
stuff the president can just declare the
Pentagon will XYZ PDQ and we're off to
the races so if you know if he wants to
put if you want to order solar panels up
on the Pentagon if he wants to order you
know that you know X percentage of all
the cars will have to be super fuel
efficient you know there's a federal
government but he has a lot of
discretion a lot of power and can use
all that for good so there's that that's
wet there's something called the
Presidential Commission on climate pcap
presidential Climate Action project that
is focused on the things the president
can do in the first hundred days that
make a difference but fundamentally
there are two big things the president
needs to focus on one is getting a price
on carbon whether it's a carbon tax or
its cap and trade we've got to get the
pricing signals going so the whole world
knows that we're moving off of carbon
and the other thing is this clean energy
smart grid because you know massive
program to get clean energy produced and
distributed everywhere in the country so
that people can plug in their cars we go
we shouldn't be burning anything we
should be able to plug our cars into a
clean energy grid the next present is to
have that as a key thing going forward
is the only thing about that there are
some creative solutions as well one of
my favorite things is in the book that's
what i call hooped used for hybrids if
you're a young person you know the word
hoopty is a a slang term for an old gas
guzzling car or clunker car so you know
cash for clunkers or poop used for
hybrids what would that mean that would
mean you have all these people mostly
low-income people they've got the stuck
with these cars that use up a tremendous
amount of gas give them the right to
drive down a city hall anywhere in the
country turn in the keys we junk that
car we
that car off the road and we give them a
federally guaranteed loan not money but
a federal guarantee for a loan they go
get like a student loan and let them
purchase a fuel-efficient car I said
well why would the government do that
well number one you're you're retiring a
whole fleet of gas guzzlers which should
alleviate some of the greenhouse gas
emissions number two you're helping
people who may be stranded in suburbs
and you know downscale suburbs and they
literally cannot drive into work okay
I'm driving for a job interview you're
helping them but number three you're
doing something a lot smarter than that
you're cutting the demand for gas
because those gas-guzzling cars are so
thirsty for gas that they push up the
demand for gas which which does push up
the price for everybody if you get those
cars off the road you drop the price of
gas for everybody because you in
aggregate you've reduced a demand for
gas so those kinds of solutions which
help poor people which help the economy
which help the earth are the kinds of
solutions that a and innovative
president could get done and we have a
whole section of those kinds of policies
in the book
the low-hanging fruit for mayors and the
United States is massive weatherization
and energy retrofit for their buildings
if you think about what you know how can
you get the biggest bang for your buck
short term to reduce carbon weatherize
you know every major building in your
city and make them thirty percent more
efficient so they use thirty percent
less power well if you're using a
coal-fired power plant that's thirty
percent less submissions right there and
you also create a bunch of jobs this is
not just a good thing to do for future
generations it's a good thing to do
right now we're about to go into a very
harsh winter and in that harsh winter
energy prices are going to be sky-high
if you thought people were screaming and
complaining about gas prices in the
summer wait until you see what happens
to people especially in the Northeast
with gap with with the home fuel prices
in the winter you can leave your car
park you can't leave your house parked
you're gonna have people having to
choose between warm meals and warm homes
and the idea of this next hurricane we
can see it coming the next hurricane is
already coming it's this home heating
crisis we're doing nothing about it and
yet the idea that we could actually take
our idled construction workers who right
now have no work are our carpenters
right now have no work and put them to
work weatherizing and solar izing and
retrofitting the the homes of low-income
people and people across the country
vulnerable people should be appealing to
him there how do you pay for it well it
pays for itself in energy savings you
need some creative financing you need to
be able to work with your local utility
but you should be able to but you should
be able to get the job done of is Lisa
weatherizing the most vulnerable homes
so that we can bring their energy bills
down and keep them warm through the
winter and that should be the first
thing that the guy you should be the
last thing that the president
does George Bush and the first thing the
new president does is focus on a massive
program for weatherization and retrofits
of buildings across the country to bring
down energy bills to bring down carbon
emissions to bring up jobs bring up home
values and to put people back to work